hello hello
is this thing working
long time listener first time caller I
don't think I've ever been this nervous
in my life I'm terrified of talking to
one person and then there's
more than five here
if you can invite people that would be
great but I'll just start talking I'm
there's so many things uh like both low
level and high level that I'm really
excited about Twitter just the speed of
innovation is super exciting
I as a podcast host
and I'm actually sitting in the podcast
Studio ironically enough right now
uh I I would love for Twitter to be to
become the best podcast listening app
because I think the best
uh conversations the best comments are
happening on Twitter one of the things
I've always missed about podcasts is
that you can't comment that YouTube is
pretty nice in that there's a comment
section but it's not as Lively as
as the the Twitter conversation Reddit
is also nice but it's a different style
it's more Community Based but I think
Twitter is This Global uh
basically a global conversation uh and
then podcast to me is a kind of
like the difference between spaces to me
spaces is fun and chaotic and then
podcast is intimacy you're sitting
across one person and you're just like
focused in on them and it's a lot less
terrifying uh but Lex uh can I can I
jump in there and comment a little
please save me Kimball yeah totally so
so I I've been playing with Twitter
spaces for the past year maybe a little
longer and
um you know I've never really been
called to do a podcast
uh but what I found was was uh Twitter
spaces is
first of all you get a feel for the live
audience it's really cool
um I think there's four or five thousand
people on this right now and that's just
cool like that that that
um there's something about the feeling
of the of the crowd being there you get
the you know instant reactions uh uh
that people can do
the the other thing that is recorded if
you choose to you choose to record it
and uh it's it what I've done I've done
everything from a free-for-all which is
a bit chaotic and I don't recommend that
but what what is really good is if you
if you just keep it between you and your
your uh the person you're interviewing
and then you have a third person that
can take questions from the audience uh
it's pretty powerful because you get you
get so many questions and I love the
Twitter users out there they're
wonderful sometimes they'll kind of go
on for a little bit or sometimes they
won't even ask a question that's where
the chaos comes in but if you um if you
if you can uh have a have a moderator
that kind of collects the questions
because oh yeah I think this will be
good speak for the person you know let
them know the handle you actually take
away the chaos and it's very very
similar to a podcast
yeah I'm actually recording this with a
camera currently and via the podcast
audio just to see like see what that
looks like if I can convert this into a
video afterwards
um so it's both audio and video
integrated I'm just playing with
different ideas here and and Twitter has
the video the live video component which
is currently separate from the Twitter
spaces and if those are integrated
that's really interesting because you
can then start doing twitch or YouTube
live type of stuff but do it on Twitter
yeah I think this could be video for
sure yeah just
um we'd all we're all in different
places the cool thing about audio is you
know it's a it's a lot less prep you
know you're obviously in a good Studio
but
um I'm sitting in my office not oh I'm
gonna be on video you might take a
little bit more time audio is so quick
and easy it there is something magical
about it
is there a way to uh if anyone has
questions uh Adam it'd be awesome if
we're oh there's like the comments thing
too
yeah absolutely Lex so on the bottom
right you'll already have 260 comments
you can click on those answer people's
questions I'm going to start bringing
people up slowly right one at a time
type of thing we got Kimball here glad
Kimball that you shared your insights
let's keep that going too and Jonna
you've joined as well so there's just
many many people that we can bring up
and there's the requests are going off
the hook at the moment so this is
fantastic Lex
um where would you like to start and
maybe Kimball how about you start is
there a question is there a topic that
you'd love to dive into with Lex or that
you'd like to ask them
well you know Lex I uh you and I have
actually never met but we've we've
talked about uh being you know you
interviewing me on your podcast and I I
generally try to stay stay out of the
podcast World Limelight just because my
brother takes up enough of that and you
know I've always I find myself a little
bit better being in the background who's
your brother
yeah exactly
but I would love your thoughts on
Twitter I'd love your thoughts on the
change that's happened
um uh if you don't mind I know you've
shared some of those already on your
tweets but tell us tell us how you feel
about things right now well I really
love the continuous UI improvements now
of course people hate them because they
people generally hate change not hate
them that's the wrong word they're sort
of surprised by them and resistant to
them and they get used to them and start
to think like for example getting the
Impressions or the views on a single
tweet and just playing around with those
ideas
is super exciting just to be able to do
it quickly now
I also wonder about
the code base which so I don't have
Insider knowledge so this is me just
saying
um
sort of generally I think Twitter's been
around a long time there's a large code
base that seems to need refactor
refactoring in order to do
high-speed uh feature generation so
that's super interesting to me to sort
of learn over time how that can be done
better and better
I believe the code base is in Scala
which is a amazing programming language
but I think not one of the more popular
ones hey Eric I see Eric Weinstein in
the audience
um
uh I mean there's
there's a like a lot of stuff uh that
I'm super excited one of the things that
just came out this last night was this
uh Impressions versus likes and what I
found fascinating is you know I've got
300 000 Twitter followers a great
community of followers I I really don't
get the the negative curls in my tweets
I'm I'm either I'm doing something
different or or or whatever I don't know
but but I what I found fascinating about
the Impressions versus uh versus likes
is I responded to your to your thinking
about uh your podcast or or maybe I
suggested you go on Twitter spaces and I
got more Impressions out of that reply
then I would get out of a normal tweet I
mean in the hundreds of thousands of of
Impressions and it it really gave me a
different view into the power of Twitter
I thought that was really interesting
you know what I'd love to see is like
the tweets that have the highest
Impressions and the lowest number of
likes so the people who are too
embarrassed to admit that they looked at
that tweet I want to see those ordered
yeah
or the butts the Bots create likes and
uh and uh what we would have to make
sure that Twitter doesn't doesn't you
know include a bot as an impression well
that's the interesting dynamic between
verified accounts versus unverf meaning
like the people that pay the Twitter
blue uh and don't the interesting
Dynamic intention there I'm really
interested to see what that star is
looking like what do you think of the
eight dollars a month for verified
uh I think it's a like like a lot of
things I think is a super interesting
idea so my gut says it's a really good
idea uh it's a good way to deal with
Bots it's a good uh way to sort of
filter out the high effort comments but
there could be complicated ways in which
it goes wrong like for example there
could be certain groups that are more
likely than others to get Twitter blue
thereby there'll be a bias that starts
to creep in
um so I don't know but I'm super excited
by trying stuff trying and failing
trying and failing and trying and
failing and through that coming up with
cool like to see I think Twitter's been
in this um uh extraordinary difficult
walking on eggshells situation for so
many years whether you're being you're a
public company and you've got to worry
about worry about your performance of
recorder or you're in the public eye and
you're just being shamed no matter what
you do
and my brother's just willing to deal
with all that and so can make changes
every day twice a day
yeah and the other thing on because I'm
a machine learning guy the the adding
more and more signals to the neural net
that does the the the Sorting of the
feed and sorting of the comments which I
think Eli has really uh pushing for is
really interesting like what kind of
signals can be integrated
to provide incentives for sort of civil
discourse but also entertaining this
course and I'm trying to maximize for
that
I love the entertaining side of Twitter
and it it's uh it doesn't happen all the
time you know oftentimes I'll get on
Twitter and it's really like a news feed
or there's some You Know Drama blah blah
blah about politics which borders me to
tears but the um but when it gets
entertaining I'm I'm in love with
Twitter I'm like man this just how do we
get more of that
hey Eric uh how you doing my brother
good to see you in the virtual digital
space what are your thoughts about
improving uh Twitter
Alex uh first of all great to see you
[Music]
um
I'm driving so if I have to cut out I
have to cut out the the way I see it uh
is that we have to separate the
engineering problem from the human
problem and just the way if you took
over an internal combustion engine
manufacturer you shouldn't set yourself
the the goal of building a truly
efficient engine because you'll never do
that uh you have to figure out at some
level where do we stop taking
responsibility for The Human Condition
uh and pretending it can be fixed as an
engineering solution I'm I think a lot
of these ideas are very entertaining and
interesting the problem of course is
that this is an Adaptive landscape and
we're talking about the fitness of
various strategies and some of those
strategies for example can be playing to
the desire to learn more or they could
be playing to the desire to watch people
get destroyed in real time uh as a
result you have to imagine that lots of
bad things are fit
and if lots of bad things are Fit
changing the rules of what constitutes
fit Behavior will
you know you'll get new baddies figuring
out a new exploits so I think one of the
things that we've got to realize is that
Twitter probably doesn't have a solution
uh in the same sense that we don't sit
around trying to come up with a fraction
for pi I don't think there really is an
engineering solution to giving everyone
real-time access to the planet and then
um
you know any brain fart or any any photo
you want to tweet out uh it can't be
stopped in real time it can get around
the planet before anybody even knows
it's happened I I just I'm cautiously
optimistic that we've got a lot of
really smart people in the room
um when it comes to talking about elon's
uh opportunity the new opportunities
um but I don't want to set ourselves up
that we're trying to solve problems that
can't be solved I think that's the
really dangerous issue I don't know I
think technology can Inspire the good
and Human Nature so I it I I think all
of us have a desire to
to learn to grow to become better people
to be kind to each other and they're if
if the Twitter creates an incentive to
do that
uh to where you get celebrated for that
I think on mass we're going to see the
effect of that that means that you just
shouldn't be optimizing blindly for
engagement because people do love drama
it seems like if you blindly optimize
for engagement it's going to take us
some dark paths I like Dan Carlin's
painful attainment episode
where he basically Dan Collins Hardcore
History best podcast of all time uh a
painful attainment where he talks about
throughout human history humans like to
gather and watch others suffer like
public executions and all that kind of
stuff and uh so that that's desire for
drama for dark dramas there in all of us
but I think also the desire to do good
is in all of us and like Twitter seems
like a really nice place to explore what
signals provide the right incentive to
be good without the hard Hammer of
censorship so without just Banning
people or Shadow Banning people but
instead providing sort of the carrot the
incentive to be the best version of
yourself I think it's possible I think
it's possible and of course you want to
deal with Bots and all that kind of
stuff but in the holiday spirit Eric
I also think there's a there's a there's
a lack of appreciation for the mute
function on Twitter and
um what what uh if you if you if you
really want to clean up your feed and be
one of those guys that maybe doesn't
want to doesn't want to uh enjoy that
particular direct piece of drama
muting is just awesome you know I'll
mute anyone for a while and then I'll
unmute them and it's it's just uh you
know there'll be some drama about
I don't know Trump tax returns oh my God
if I ever if I have to hear any more
things about Trump it's just boring me
to tears I just mute I'm like I'm out
I'm not interested in the drama
um now there might be another area of
drama that I I say I do I am interested
in like I I cared a lot about what's
going on in Ukraine and I'm not trusting
what people are saying because it's just
it's a lot of opinions it's hard to tell
what's true but I but I am not muting
that because I'm I'm genuinely curious
except because I believe we are we are
in a tough spot of how do you get just
peace in a time when you have this bully
Putin and how do you I mean that's a
fascinating problem that I care about so
I don't mute that and so I I think that
that that feature is just underused in
Twitter and I think um uh uh my brother
has plans to incorporate it into just
the algorithm as well if people start
muting that that that that should also
be less popular
uh I'm not in dispute by the way I don't
know that we've ever spoken with each
other so nice to meet you Kimball nice
to be here
so the way I see it is that there are
lots of things that I'm not interested
in that are also interested in me
and
um there's a lot of drama that's kicked
up
which I don't think it's a question so
much of I don't know what how much
Kimball you've been through the uh the
ringer where you get these very
organized campaigns that will often
sometimes just use a single phrase from
ten thousand accounts
and its effect is extremely strong
particularly on peop people who are not
savvy to the way in which
um individual reputations are targeted
so one of them yeah and you mean you
mean personal to you right like not not
you're watching someone not not you're
watching someone happy I'm watching Lex
go through this right now in real time
there is an organized campaign at some
level which lots of people are piling on
to because I figured out I send them
love I send them love right back so they
I bring it on first of all I'll bring it
on and second of all I always respond
with love okay there you go in my case I
did go through it twice during covet I
have a restaurant company and we had to
close our restaurants and I got publicly
shamed in ways that was just not fair I
just I we were not we didn't have any
choices uh and yet I also have empathy
for the people that that were suffering
because I mean as my industry was a
disaster it can still struggling frankly
but yeah been going through the ringer
and being publicly shamed really
freaking sucks I I will agree with that
so what I'm trying to get at that is
that when your brother for example had
sensitivities to how his real-time
location was compromised a lot of what
we hear on social media is far too
simplistic to govern the technological
problems we've created for ourselves we
say things like oh I'm interested in a
diversity of opinions well are you
interested in a diversity of opinions
that include different ideas about what
two plus three equals I certainly am not
um are am I interested in an enormous
form of anonymous accounts uh targeting
the amygdalas of my relatives for
example so that if the next family
gathering everyone comes up to me and
says oh Eric it's pretty brutal that
you're such a fraud and a fake and a
grifter into this and that and I'm
thinking well if you use the word
grifter I know where you've been because
nobody uses that in normal speech yeah
right
whatever we're going through it's not
just a question of oh I don't prefer to
have that in my feed it's a question of
This is full-on war between different
factions Who and the most important
thing that I can point out is notice
that everyone who refuses to sing from
the hymnal that is used by everything
from the New York Times to MSNBC to Yale
has a reputation online as being some
kind of morally reprehensible person who
can barely think out to defraud others
in other words there there really is a
targeting of everything that doesn't
subscribe to the institutional consensus
and I think if we're not open about the
fact that Twitter is creating problems
that may not have been anticipated
correctly even by the U.S Constitution I
think we're going to come to understand
that we're in a new world and we can't
go back to the past to search for
answers and lastly just one thing Lex I
think it's fantastic that you maintain
this incredible positivity and optimism
I think it's one of the things that
people love about you it's very
important that you or somebody who
brings that be in the room but it is
also important that people who can see
the negative a mile away and the dangers
that are created be in the same room and
that those people be able to remain in
the room long term in order to solve
this problem it may not actually have a
solution thanks guys yeah Eric one thing
I just want to make a point I I did go
through it twice during clover but
actually one of it was on on tick tock
and the other one was on Twitter uh
there were like 18 months apart but it
really is the same thing same same issue
and um uh Tick Tock was worse uh I'm
like I don't even use tick tock and I
was like oh that like you said people
coming up to me on the street saying I
can't believe you did that to be like oh
what this is covered we we have to close
but we're acquired by the government but
but
um uh Tick Tock was uh was also very bad
so it's an it's something to think it's
not just Twitter that's important to
appreciate
and I tend to be optimal I tend to see
that as not a problem of Twitter or Tick
Tock but of human nature and I think
technology can uh help alleviate that
this kind of pylon effect that people
generally engage in on when we're all
connected when there's millions of us
connected that kind of stuff is going to
happen and I also think that
not taking it to I know it's hard to to
say that but yeah I've been attacked
quite a bit but not taking it seriously
kind of laughing it off and also not
responding to it with negativity
responding with positivity I think
um not in some kind of naive way but
just it's a great way to resist these
natural movements I think just putting
Good Vibes out there is going to and
incentivizing that for the for people
who use Twitter I think would do a lot
of good
so I just if you believe that most
people are good and want to do good I
think technology can provide the right
incentives then you own that that takes
the signals and sorts the feed and
Source the comments can um
can sort of maximize uh the good in each
of us but yeah there's definitely
there's definitely sort of political
factions there's there's all kinds of
battles going on but that's human nature
that's a beautiful thing the fact that
we can at scale this discuss the war in
Ukraine uh discuss geopolitics the fact
that maybe on Twitter spaces you'll get
uh one of these days we'll have Putin
zolensky
yeah uh speaking speaking in Russia and
Twitter I mean that's really exciting I
mean I I don't and and but that's also a
huge huge huge huge responsibility uh
for the algorithm for the the automated
uh aspects of Twitter anyway this is uh
the Ukraine one is a great example where
where everyone well not everyone most
people have a different opinion
um around around Ukraine but I think
everyone is a is taking it very
seriously and and at least what I can
tell on Twitter that the Twitter
Community is taking it very seriously as
they should you know this is the first
time we've had a land war in in uh in
western civilization in in about 60
years and um uh we have a we have a uh
what do you call it the underdog and the
bully when it's easy for America to back
Ukraine and yet we have we have to
remember Russia has got enough nukes to
destroy the world
we should all be thinking about peace
and and I I have been encouraged when I
tweet her in around Ukraine which I'm a
pro Ukraine guy but I also say hey guys
let's not forget the goal here is peace
not not the Ukraine is is helping us
should should all be helped we should
all be working towards peace and I'll
get the I'll get people you know
arguing with me but it's civil and I I
think that it's it's that's great
speaking of peace and War live high
hi everyone hello
Eric
last last words because uh the end is
near as Frank Sinatra said uh Liv would
you have any suggestions how to improve
Twitter
any thoughts
yeah so I've only just jumped in so I
don't want to repeat I'll see anything
that's already been discussed but
yeah you're always original Liv say that
again
you're always original
even more pressure now
um
I mean the thing that's always in my
mind is like the sort of tyranny of
metrics right when we're always
optimizing for what we're reducing the
trouble with social media is that it
reduces the entirety of Human Experience
down to these like singular metrics how
many likes do we get how many retweets
Etc and so that naturally acts as a sort
of funnel into making us optimized for
the most incendiary things we can think
of you know there's a wide range of
emotions that that can potentially
trigger people to sort of share our
content but it seems like out of all the
sort of common human emotions anger is
the most effective one at doing that
which is why we're sort of it's not
surprising because it's a very active
emotion essentially it sort of motivates
us into into tribalistic ways and so
it's no surprise that it's then sort of
amplifying all this polarization that
we're seeing so
um in terms of how do we how do we
reduce the
the
the
you know they instead of having less
anger that as the stick driving us to
share stuff we need more carrots that
are happy and exciting and inspiring to
to make us share more positive content
and I don't have an answer of how to you
know how we optimize for that but it's
something to do with the metrics and how
do we change the metrics
um so that they Inspire us and reward us
for sharing more positive content
um
did anyone have any ideas
well we talked a little bit about that
that I am totally a total agreement
adding signals to the neuron that that
that incentivize uh civil discourse
sort of high effort comments even if
it's disagreement all that kind of stuff
so uh just adding more and more signals
that the neon that can sort to feed to
sort the comments sort the suggestions
properly and then doing the discovery of
content well search and Discovery
YouTube was incredible at that and for
Twitter to do search and Discovery
better it would be amazing
I think also having the replies either
you know if you if you make a comment or
make a tweet and you get a whole bunch
of replies
most of them are yeah I totally agree or
I don't agree but but sorting and
finding the ones that actually have
content would be would be nice even if
that content may not be you know make
make you happy it's just uh uh when you
get a lot of replies it's nice to to it
would be if there was a way I'm sure
it's very straightforward to just get
the more the more uh more in-depth
responses a little uh higher so you have
something to respond to
actually one idea as well what about if
we had a because part of the problem of
like the binary yes I like this or no I
dislike it and therefore I'm going to
dunk on it by quote tweeting it
um what if we had some kind of slider
instead where like ah you know what I I
somewhat agree with this uh you know so
there's like a granularity you can give
it like a score out of 10 of what you
agree with it you know how much you
agree with it and then the things that
um and then and that that would give
like more information that the algorithm
could then choose to boost the things
that you know perhaps are more moderate
essentially that people are like you
know I'm yeah I seven out of ten agree
with this that sounds like it's a more
nuanced moderate take and therefore you
could it could artificially amplify
those kind of those kind of um
tweets essentially I think it also would
get people uh as long as that is not a
public number I'm not sure if you'd want
that in my case I could agree with
something that that I know would be
because of my last name would be would
be taken out of context but I actually
do agree with it and I say you know I
agree with a seven out of ten and and
that is not a public number
I would be I would probably do that a
lot
yeah
well this was uh an incredible first
time experience for me I'm glad
I'm still freaking out Eric is so
beautiful to see it Kimbo it's great to
meet you and Liv uh I hope to see you
soon uh it's good it's great we're doing
great I know you don't know me that well
um you are doing
faces just wanted to put that out there
all right for your first time next 10
out of 10. next time it'll be an 11 out
of 10 something to uh to Aspire to all
right uh goodbye friends I love you all
see ya